[Music]
I'm Deirdre Friel come join me on the
set of physical
welcome to Body by Sheila Sheila is
everything is so authentically 80s hello
we had chords they've picked amazing
colors everything has this reflection of
femininity just as what women have been
wanting yes
my office it's amazing I just saw it for
the first time this morning so we're
going to learn about it together I love
that yeah the art in Greta's office is a
direct reflection of the weird art in
the Hauser house I'm actually going to
bring you through the set while we're
filming this is my dresser Mo she knows
more about me than my boyfriend this is
our front desk we have logos on the
shirt
this is the merchandise we sell at the
company leotards for 9.95 I mean come on
take a moment put it in your mind
you're welcome you look super hot
[Music]
talk about what you like about being on
a female lead team because females are
the best and yeah who says women can't
do it all this is Jen Hamilton she does
all the choreography you see on the show
she took the time to teach me
choreography this year which is so great
a gargantuancy a little Pat on my own
back don't mind if I do that's a wrap
[Music]
foreign